man macht ja das zu Hause vom Kind
kaputt mit soer Trennung wenig wieig B
den
[Applaus]
wichtig Familie es ist so viel me liebes
trennt
[Musik]
groß
die
ich frage
geht Familie versched System
mit F
Familie mit und familieotz
immer Str hier mit auf
ver ich würde einfach dann schon
erwarten dass man die Bettwäche wech ich
erwte viel weniger V R jetzt in der
klassische bezung für mich ist das jetzt
viel wertvoller trotz Trainig mit der
Familie geht wier Frage
wie tschü faszinierend Thema der tren
perinander und logisch mit Schmerz
meistens verbunden und so aber getrennt
die Wege aber be hing im SPI sie der
blibt die gemeinsame riesige Verbindig
und Projekt sag jetzt mal so h blibt das
heißt man muss immer noch eigentlich
zammen entscheiden wel Schuh wel socker
legen Sie an wie viel Zucker dürf sie
essen AUO vielleicht mal banali oder
oder Ries weich wo man muss ST und
bezieh schwiig funktioniert immer
Kompromiss oder so zuingen aber wie ist
es wenn
man W vi
Verst vorstell mit de frageff n Stefan
schon v geburtre
5050 diej zwi v w hier dieim
Vater
schwiig Moment für n und steefan die
beide immer mein verched jetzt wasum
King
fster n mit der tren viel vertrau Stefan
verloren der Moment wo wo die tren und
Frau
ist mir nicht seh
Vertu mir nicht sicher Schwangerschaft
bis Z Punk ob überhaup vaterf war das
nicht nach der TR unklar fraging
unsichtig im doppbett schlafen bis zur
Entscheidig Wing wie
oft professionell
Mediation schlechum n Kommunikation mit
dem steef nötig fahen das
ist für in FR
aber für Fred V vom ganz merk das auf
emotionale sich
wirklichinz
wie sehr lang große Mühe und immer noch
m drum persönlich
stean
önlich Situation wieon mit deran her ich
merke es
istes friedlich neant
sie sehr wenig vonand mit was King ma
her Treff sie und drum ist conclusion
ich ich mus ganz viel los und im
Vertrauen bliben vertrau zum B das Tring
beim Stefan gut ess g Kare Regel z. ke
Zucker was
jetzt
ne ne aber
dast
nicht und
Grundsatzfrage
philosophiew Stefan King
dprech we nicht wieag verlft und die was
geh
konsumiert them aufgriff nachfragt wie
macht und D macht
locker
und
L
t Kleider
Ving für steefan ist
zrangig ist komisch
[Musik]
dieider
aberch wie Ex
vstell
trotz und H zwischen z
husf Familien dieätzig deckt sich mit
der Studie V genöis Kommission für
familiefage z befinde Ving mit Z besser
no schlechter aus der Durchschnitt von
Dering
schwitz
automatische ist da h
[Musik]
dran
aber
wie
Besch wor
aber ja
also es ist doch vertrau
da wichtig fo mir hoff geht odig sehr
schön
wahsinnig und
das mit
n mit Teile die Freud und nicht das
genau
stimmt Freud Universum und Freud
universumh
blattusdückt und was heißt das teile ich
glbich relativ reduziert und auf
emotionaler mus glaub ich das wenig
vorhanden
ma
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit mama
mama
[Musik]
mealom
schalom
steefan Wege im gich
Quartier nicht ganz
klar
dieat oder ja das weiß ich das das und
ich GLB das falsch verstanden für
mich Kind ja okay
aber mir klar die
verantw
Option du
noch
so für steefan ist
Kampf zu
50%
K existenell und die sehr
wenig Person also irgendwie
profession
das Schlechte V
von
Schl
erwachsfah passier
sch Kontakt
keine Gesprach geführt mit der Behörde
sie n WhatsApp
kommuniziert Wort mit
Wort persönlich
Treff akzeptieren das
die und ke und hab nicht die ganz zit
Angriffe gefühlt das jetzt ja völlig
falsch machen und ja und aber irgendwie
Kind und so
[Musik]
ja
und Stefan zu
irgenditpk zur Diskussion gest n ist
aber reale
Angst so richtig am platzü mit also
Vater
richtigen Ort richtige Setting weniger
wie eigent bis den wichtigste aufgab
wegnimmt und
Angst also wenn wenig vi
vi weniger trainere ja das mit mir
weniger
ot mein Konflikt n steefan Chance
Vorteil
vterier
irendwi wirklich bis zum letz
und und kenholen oder
und immer
ohne
GL mit dem
steefan und
n
Privileg
Leist die alternieren
diech pa
J
felt
W super schöne Idee
aber völlig nicht
funktionierting verloren
und
für
dief nach Woche beim
vateruch
zwechter tren vor 6 Jahr im NM he King
hier fix familienw im N und die
trch Stress v
pler mit der Hinger le K Verl später am
ab n und Sam übernimmt sie te sich immer
Zimmer und Bett einfach nicht gichsitig
das ist sozusagen das elternchlaf
Schlafzimmer guck das ist mein Bereich
ja und dann oben hat Sam so einen Tabler
mit einfach den schwarzen Sachen das
langt ja ist geil also ich weiß auch ich
habe nicht so viele Kleider hier auch
noch mal oben von Sam und unten von mir
sonder we Zimmer für die Person Kind
frei sie das Verm
sie
freundschaftlich wir sind einfach gute
Freunde mit
Kind
brüderlichesfh gegenüber habe also er
ist für mich ganz klar
Familie entwickl aber von liebesbezieh
zur Freundschaft ja was ist mat
entscheidend also es ist glaube ich
Match entscheidend dass beide an
denselben Punkt kommen
emotional sich so voneinander gelöst zu
haben dass man eben wieder
freundschaftlich miteinander umgehen
kann und sich halt gegenseitig
freundschaftlich auch immer noch
wertschätzen kann ich meine wir haben
natürlich auch uns auch nicht ausstehen
können für ein Moment aber gleichzeitig
haben wir zwei Kinder zusammen und uns
sind die Kinder ja auch wichtig und wir
möchten den Kindern ja auch nicht ihre
Familie kaputt
machen ich weiß es nicht s in welches
Zimmer
hier aber da hat auch zwei Steckdosen
ich habe einfach immer so Probleme mit
deinem deinen Kabeln du hast gerne so
überall
Kabel aber da hat auch zwei steck
was GI da gewisse Regel gerade Intimität
Sexualität jetzt wenn wirim bet oder
nein aber also Regeln gibt es nicht also
man kann eigentlich machen was man will
ja
und man kann machen was man will aber
also da haben wir auch drüber gesprochen
man muss einf glau ich drüber
sprechen zurück im familienest ab der
Sekunde
wenig fr sie ABW zwischen der eig
Bedürfnis den von Dering und flüig schf
begleitet die Person ist die quasi aus
der Beziehung raus oder merkt dass es
nicht mehr stimmt hat man ja hat man
diese
Gedanken dass man Schuldgefühle hat den
Kindern gegenüber weil sich ja das ganze
Verhältnis auch verändert oder man hat
ja auch Angst wie ist die Beziehung
nachher mit den Eltern von Sam mir z.B
mit den Schwiegereltern sozusagen es gab
dann auch die Situation wo dann die
Lehrpersonen von der Mio gesagt haben
dass man es merkt dass es ihr gerade
nicht so gut geht wegen der Trennung und
so aber ich ja sind dann halt auch
vielleicht oft Projektionen von außen
wenn andere Leute hören oh die Eltern
haben sich getrennt dass das jetzt wie
schlimm ist für die Kinder auf mir nach
mchen im
nmzt was ausprobiert theoretisch
großartig aber
Realität geminsam husut meine logisch
danke doch mal die vergessene fest
[Musik]
Bachofen turniert schon
wieder bis
morgen B ne bis Freitag
W
[Musik]
tschüss
und ehrlich g ist recht schön
vorstellig
BR Papa mit Mama vi Familie Nacht oder
so
ja für mir tröstliche
vorstellig aber ich muss sagen dass ich
Meter dankbar bin dass S geschafft trotz
strit mitpunkt
ST ganzers Lauf r% von tren V mit
Minderjährige Schw Konflikt und die LE
tragenzwis King morgen Christian
ja
genau früher ja ist pädagogische
Familienbegleiter und n sich den Familie
Konflikt tren
lös s er die aufgab er
machtübergab der STR V
derübergabing regäßig eskaliert
übernimmt das für se hallo hallo guten
Morgen
mal
guteit zu
Mama ist immer so entspannte
übergab zu dir
einfach lang da
also am Anfang ist sicher nicht
nicht
undfangüber beg
übergangslö es nimmt der Schusslinie V
Konflikt das ist so
viellzte so viel Angst da das es einfach
wen brucht
der Situation vi
geh das da oder
nicht hier bessere das ist
matentscheidend der Fokus muss weg vor
bez zum Expartner her zum Kind sobald
die Sicherheit oder das Zugeständnis h V
ih ja mir s Geschicht jetzt geht's drum
beste für Kind machen
der nimmt so
fah der Christian schaff für Stig Fred
kopig
hftrag verstige Familie begeglei
VES undwachsen schutzbehörde normal
übergab
mitist geht mit
dem spter
andere kindchutzmaßnahme schwizhang mit
hochstrge tren es geh zu dergabe V Ch
immer wieder vor
dterfig maach
für Begleit Christian
aktuellpricht mit
teamkolleges
waswet nlich genau Freud ja du
undübergab zurück
ist Stum drin SP Kind oder will sie ja
grundsätzlichf Loyalitätskonflikt
Wenning quasi wie
musentsche
und wie
nicht gebor
sich dar fü W das
VI ja
nicht
Begle zum
Z ganz ang und trenicht
kenen die
m
Sch qu King Z Wochen für stung und
Begleit und so viel verpasst gar nicht
wie recht Frage aber was
ist
schwierigste
schwiig
soicher
sie die
Mut der Christian unstüz mit dem Ziel
betre
derteil für ist klar die alternieren die
im Grundsatz das gut füring und
Elter Sicht vom Kind Kind nicht besser
aber das ist einfach mus bewusst
dasarbeit braucht od das VI noch nicht
Punkt und viele schaff nicht alle Punkt
unterstü
W wie die
Familie konflikthafte Bezi aber muss
sagen das ist viel viel schlimmer die
Erniedrigung der kracht das grei der Ton
mitüber entwickl so dermaß gefrlich
und ja muss
wie ma Mens
Verstand tut noch gut
da
[Musik]
Schwiz g immer meh Gebot für z STR Elter
mit der tren überforder sie Ziel von den
Kurs Mediation Coachings ist d das gcht
muss Entscheid wie es mit der Familie
wier
geht für mich steht let
familieuch Petra und Ramon mit den
beideing ganz normale Familie K man
meine
aber W
immer
vor z Wochen oder
so für mich und
[Musik]
für me sch und für als Familie
aber
was
alternative getr
oderchelt oder
klaro
mach oder es finanziell macht überhaup
ke so viel Sache n die geburte
unglaublich oder das
Wahnsinn und da sind ja so verbinden die
Ereignis
das das
schwe und zwar unabhängig
[Musik]
DAV K körperlich sexuell oder
nicht du schlafst der
zB V be machen
[Musik]
AES Bezi m
überdenk für mich überhaupt nicht mehr
funktioniert und ich bin glücklich und
ich für mich
wichtigste dass es mir gut funktioniert
nicht
und dann hab wir machen das wieder gut
miteinand oder Form immer ich erwarte
viel weniger vom RAM jetzt wie in der
klassische bezierung ke ja schon mal
wieder
machen
viel viel
toleranter oder wenn viel sachlich es W
Sa mis es D vielleicht her irgend Z
rückblickendb lebesbeziirk aber irgend
für mich ist das jetzt viel wertvoller
ich immer alles dafür D od der kan
alles Petra ist halbe Jahr neue
bezieg gut dan soichtig und auch dank
Freund dass er offen ist dem gegenüber h
mituch
kämpf aber ich glaub besser das länger
das K desto besser wird so gemeinsame W
oder so neues
Aufbau ja das ist
so vielenig also iche das Bedürfnis
überhaupt
nicht im Moment kann ich nicht
vorstellen mit
warte mal
ja mal vor vorstell dass er auch B
woh ja
g Wegstrecke von dir so ma beide
Kommunikation miting inern
informiert abgt oder oder max wer ist
der frü von
Mami
[Musik]
Simon jachuldigung wieder Seil h
also anders verzähle oder so und S Hand
immer noch gern und wir sind beide für
Sie da aber
m ja und
du
aberck oder Nein
super ut wow krasse
scheiß
best für mich so Familie aber schon sch
viel Familie mit dem besten Freund
viicht aber
es
mit Abstand knst mir mit Abstand am
beste und best meine wie beste Freunde
die li ich auch
[Gelächter]
irgendwi cool verer
[Musik]
stü genau WIP
ster wie du dich
[Musik]
verändert be die
got
und auf
[Musik]
transportier der Reise vi Kapitel und
die vi sch zeig ja die train einfach die
gesch und das ist so viel Faktor in SP
wie Training verläuftich jetzt fragt ja
Tipp tren miting W ich sag l
das
liebesbezieh bezieh trenen das zwei
verschiedene Sachen ist so einfach g und
dais vom schwierigste jetzt bin ich aber
gespannt auf EU Blick was mit vom Film
oderfah gemacht mit und tren Kommentar
und meh we l V geht unbedingt F
[Musik]
play